[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 78 sur tv78
nous sommes le mercredi 4 octobre voici
les titres de
l'actualité jusqu'à dimanche c'est la
Semaine européenne du développement
durable exposition projection balade et
atelierers des animations se tiennent
partout en France à 50 ans en Eveline
les associ sittion de transition
écologique se sont retrouvés pour la
fête des possibles ça s déroulé du côté
de plaisir au centre commercial au
shopping répar café conseil pour réduire
ses déchets entretien de son vélo les
visiteurs ont pu bénéficier de
différentes astuces la 5e nuit du droit
se déroule ce soir comme tous les 4
octobrees l'occasion de célébrer la 65e
le 65e anniversaire de la constitution
de la 5e République dans les ivelines
plusieurs lieux ouvreent public le
tribunal judiciaire et le tribunal
administratif de Versailles ou enc
encore la Faculté de droit de
l'Université Versailles 50 ans en
ibinagu en cours interview avec son
doyen Franck Monier il est le meilleur
ami de l'homme et a désormais sa Semaine
Nationale le chien est célébré jusqu'à
dimanche à un événement et de nombreuses
animations c'était le cas il y a
quelques jours au club d'éducation
canine à morpa où nous étions présents
et puis les invités du 78 en 2è partie
d'émission on y parle d'Octobre Rose le
mois de sensibilisation contre le cancer
du sein qui touche plus de 60000 femmes
chaque année en France une nouvelle fois
la mobilisation est forte pour faire
avancer la lutte contre la maladie coup
de projecteur ce soir sur deux actions
le marathon rose de Cassio PA et les
tours de la victoire à bai et ce sera
avec mes deux invités qui sont d'ors et
déjà installés avec moi en plateau sur
la droite nous avons Isabelle n bonsoir
bonsoir alors vous êtes membrre vous de
l'association cassiopa je le disais elle
organise donc le marathon rose qui passe
par les ivelines on en dira un peu plus
tout à l'heure mais déjà peut-être
quelques mots d'introduction sur
casiopea quelle est cette association
alors c'est une association qui a été
créé en 2015 par Nathalie David qui est
une grande sportive et qui a été touchée
elle-même par la maladie qui a continué
à pratiquer du sport pendant ses
traitements pendant la maladie et cetera
et qui a eu l'idée de cette association
puisque aujourd'hui c'est prouvé que par
le sport on peut aider à lutter contre à
supporter la maladie à supporter les
traitements à même lutter contre les
effets secondaires des traitements et
euh même
à éventuellement empêcher les récidives
donc on en parlera tout à l'heure de de
ce marathon rose mais aussi voir comment
le sport justement peut aider dans la
guérison à vos côté il y a Sabrina
tourmetz bonsoir bonsoir vous êtesvous
MRE adjointte en charge de l'urbanisme à
ba alors on va pas parler d'urbanisme ce
soir avec vous mais plutôt des actions
de la Commune à l'occasion de ce mois
d'Octobre Rose je le disais il y a
notamment un événement phare qui se
déroule ce dimanche c'est les tours de
la victoire avec un objectif on aura
aussi l'occasion d'en parler tout à
l'heure dem 24 tours bah tout simplement
pourquoi la commune est-elle engagée
dans la lutte contre le le cancer du
sein et et se mobilise donc pour Octobre
Rose alors la ville de Ba se mobilise
pour la lutte contre le cancer du sein
un mois pour sensibiliser au dépistage à
ce titre nous sommes partenaire de
l'association et Don la recherche qui a
pour but de soutenir la recherche
médicale sous toutes ses formes c'est un
c'est un fléo qui qui nous concerne tous
et par le biais de nos associations et
des actions de de la commune nous nous
nous nous nous favorisons C toutes les
actions contre le pour le dépissage du
du cancer du sein du cancer du sein qui
touche en France une une femme sur neuf
et en plateau également avec nous il y a
Gabrielle Gontier bonsoir de la
rédaction TV 78 et tout de suite avec
vous ce sont les infos du
jour et on commence Gabriel avec un
incendie survenu hier dans les ivelines
oui la C CBRE école de commerce à
chaussé a pris feu ce mardi soir peu
après 20h au même moment le chef
d'entreprise et haut fonctionnaire
Jacques Atali était en conférence devant
des étudiants 150 personnes ont été
évacuées mais aucune victime n'est à
déploré les 60 pompiers ivelinois sont
parvenus à arrêté l'incendie aux
alentours de 23h le toit de
l'amphithéâtre blondeo s'est effontré
les autres bâtiments étaient épargnés
eux pour l'instant aucune décision
Grégory n'a été prise concernant une
suspension des activités de HC selon un
communiqué de l'université on parle à
présent de fs2i c'est un fond de
solidarité entre les départements
franciliens oui tout à fait vous l'avez
dit on l'appelle fs2i il a été créé en
2019 et il a pour vocation de porter une
soixantaine de dossiers à vis visés
sociétal et départemental entre les SEP
départements franiliens les présidents
des départements étaient réunis ce mardi
3 octobre au domaine de Madame
elliisabeth à Versailles ils ont
présenté les 158 millions d'euros qui
seront alloués aux différents projets
dans les Evelin il y aura le financement
par pardon d'un institut de recherche
autour du sport et du handicap au Mau je
vous propose qu'on écoute Pierre Bédier
le président du Département des ivelines
c'est un fond
qui porte des projets qui ne pourraitêre
pas porté qu'au seul échelon
départemental qui ne sont pas de la
compétence régionale et donc on ne peut
pas demander à la région de payer ce
qu'elle n'a pas à payer et donc ce sont
les départements qui s'associent et qui
mettent un peu d'argent pour justement
porter ses projets c'est c'est vraiment
la démonstration que la coopération
entre les collectivités produit des
résultats tout à fait remarquables et on
va parler à présent Gabriel d'une
plateforme créée par l'État oui
histologe vient de voir le jour pour
lutter contre le mallogement la
plateforme permet en une seule démarche
sur son site de signaler sa situation
une fois le signalement expliqué la
plateforme se charge de transmettre
votre dossier au services territoriaux
le mallogement c'est plus de 7 millions
de ménages qui vivent dans des
conditions très difficiles sans accès à
l'au au chauffage ou au sanitaire avec
ce logiciel le gouvernement espère
trouver des solutions rapides sur 52
départements déployés plus de 16000
personnes ont été enregistrées et plus
de 1700 foyers sont sortis du mogement
on termine avec un événement qui se
déroulait cet après-midi du côté du
centre commercial Westfield véisi 2
autour d'une célèbre émission de
télévision oui les fans de l'émission de
télévision fortbyard ont pu rencontrer
les célèbres passe-partout et passe
Murail ce mercredi 4 octobre à véis vill
cou le JO est accompagné de l'animateur
Olivier mine tous les trois ils ont
présenté un action game officiel de
l'émission installé au sein du centre
commercial vous l'avez dit on écoute les
réactions au micro de Michel elmidoro le
concept en fait c'est comme dans forbard
c'est de c'est d'être en immersion dans
dans l'esprit en tout cas de ce que de
ce qu'elle programme et et de ce qu'elle
for il y a donc des cellules il y a des
épreuves qui ont été reconstituées et
recréées comme dans forbyard il y a
évidment la salle du trésor il y a le
Conseil on s'y croirait et c'est une
belle aventure pour les gens qui vont
venir essayer tous ces jeux et les
tester bien sûr j'y participe depuis 34
ans ce jeu il est mythique on a envie
d'y jouer on a envie de le découvrir
pour bien s'amuser en famille c'est
passe partout sur
tv78 forbyard vous êtes fun en
plateau petite oui mes enfants également
même réponse petite oui et en plus je
suis de la région donc forcément
ouis merci Gabriel pour toutes ces
informations alors contrairement à ce
qui a été indiqué de temps en temps nous
sommes bien le mercredi 4 octobre et non
le mardi 3 octobre il y a eu les deux
dates qui sont affichés au cours de vos
informations mais nous sommes bien le
mercredi 4 octobre et si vous aussi vous
êtes témoins d'une actualité qui vous
fait réagir près de chez vous n'hésitez
pas à nous la partager sur les réseaux
sociaux en utilisant le hashtag 7
news la nuit du droit revient ce soir
pour une 5e édition en Île-de-France
plus de 32 institutions participent à ce
rendez-vous notamment le tribunal
judiciaire le tribunal administratif qui
sont installés à Versailles mais aussi
l'ordre des avocat ou encore
l'université Versailles à 50 ans en
Yveline le thème cette année patrimoine
droit et justice le doyen de la Faculté
de droit de l'vsq explique l'importance
du rendez-vous au micro de Gabriel
Gontier et de Mélanie
poquet je suis Franck Monier historien
du droit et doyen de la Faculté de Droit
et Sciences Politiques de Versailles
la nuit du droit c'est une manifestation
qui est organisée tous les 4 octobres le
4 octobre étant la date anniversaire de
la promulgation de la Constitution de la
5e République et la première édition de
la Nuit du droit a été organisée à
l'initiative du président du Conseil
constitutionnel Laurent Fabius il
s'agissait de célébrer les 60 ans de
notre
Constitution l'objectif de la nuit du
droit est d'ouvrir les lieux de droit à
la société cela nous permet d'aborder
des thématiques en lien avec l'actualité
en lien également avec le quotidien et
les lieux de vie des administrés tout ça
avec comme objectif final comme dessin
de rendre accessible le droit de
démystifier le droit et également
d'améliorer la connaissance des métiers
du
droit il est important de de faire
connaître le le droit aux citoyens aux
administrés de façon à non seulement
améliorer la connaissance du droit mais
également à pousser les administrés à
faire valoir leurs droits beaucoup plus
facilement avec moins
d'appréhension et jusqu'au 8 octobre
c'est la Semaine européenne du
développement durable à cette occasion
de nombreuses animations sont organisées
partout en France une fois n'est pas
coutume une fête des possibles s'est
tenu au centre commercial au shopping
grand plaisir le reportage de Mélanie
poquet et de vous Gabriel Gontier on va
mettre dedans la M
d'accord un atelier de bouturage dans un
lieu insolite le 30 septembre dernier
une quinzaine d'association du
territoire rivelinois organiser la fête
des possibles dans le centre commercial
au shopping de plaisir pour rencontrer
les gens on pense qu'un samedi dans une
galerie commerciale il peut y avoir
beaucoup de gens à voir effectivement
les gens
voilà on peut interpeller les gens dans
leur acte quotidien de de consommation
on en entend parler tous les jours hein
sur dans les actualités la crise
climatique est là donc on ce qu'on veut
montrer aujourd'hui c'est qu'il y a des
solutions qu'on peut faire à notre
niveau de citoyens le but de cette fête
rendre visibles les initiatives
citoyennes une démarche qui a convaincu
le centre commercial aujourd'hui chacun
doit se soucier aussi de l'avenir social
écologique de de la planète et ça rentre
vraiment sur la stratégie en fait RSE
que l'entreprise nud et citrus
gestionnaur et propriétaire du des
centres commerciaux souhait développer
répare café conseil pour réduire ses
déchets douit yourself entretien de vélo
et les associations proposaient divers
ateliers tout au long de la journée la
per B malheureusement elle est
irréparable donc ils font pas de miracle
mais c'est essayé et la deuxième le PC
bah ils ont trouvé le problème en deux
petits C de sous dur ils m'ont réparé
mon PC et maintenant il refonctionne
nickel la fête des possiles s'inscrivait
dans le cadre de la Semaine européenne
du développement durable qui dure elle
jusqu'au 8 octobre prochain al semaine
du développement durable nuit du droit
on l' compris se passe beaucoup de
choses en ce moment mais ce mercredi 4
octobre c'est aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
une journée mondiale est-ce que vous
avez une idée autour de la table de
quelle journée mondiale il s'agit
Gabriel j'ai eu quelques infos en
rédaction donc je vais laisser les
invités ça vous dit rien une petite
journée mondiale peut-être pouvez-vous
aiguiller nos nos invités je croav end
je croisoir entendu mais la la journée
mondiale du chien c'est ça non pres je
me suis trop Journée mondiale des
animaux c'est même plus large qui donc
se déroule le 4 octobre quel est votre
animal préféré je fais un petit tour de
table le chat on va dire le chien le
chat le chat de de ce côté on va dire le
chat le chat aussi c'est de c'est chien
et chat chien et chat bon vous me tendez
la per chez Isabelle puisqu'on va parler
du chien à présent puisque il est
célébré jusqu'à dimanche à l'occasion de
la première Semaine nationale du chien
donc il y a une journée mondiale des
animaux mais aussi une semaine nationale
du chien qui se déroule en ce moment à
cette occasion des animations sont
proposé dans les Evelin c'était le cas
il y a quelques jours au club
d'éducation canine à morpa comment bien
éduquer son animal connaître ses
capacités ou sensibiliser au risque de
mort sure Julien Leroi avec la voix de
Michel el midoro
copier Spike célèbre sa journée jusqu'à
dimanche prochain la première semaine
nationale du chien est organisé dans
l'Hexagone promenade en forêt
démonstration d'attelage ou atelier
pédagogique diverses manifestations
visent à promouvoir le rôle bénéfique
des canidés et forment les futurs
adoptants au club d'éducation canine à
morpa des présentations été proposées au
public ce dimanche 1er octobre vous avez
également pu voir des démonstrations de
ring qui est un programme
national de qui allie des exercices
d'obéissance des exercices de saut et un
programme de défense on travaille plus
dans le jeu que dans le que dans la
contrainte donc il faut capter son chien
et puis lui lui faire comprendre qu'on
veut jouer avec lui pour l'amener à
faire des exercices une occasion aussi
de mettre en avant l'activité du club
lors de ses portes ouvertes ici des
éducateurs diplômés et bénévoles
enseignent au propriétaire comment bien
éduquer leur chien une manière de mieux
vivre avec son animal il y en a pas mal
des gens qu's ont des chiens comme
compagnie mais ils savent pas se
comporter avec des chiens et ils ne
savent pas pas
comment s'exprime un chien sensibilisé
au langage canin dans ce club à morpa
l'accent était aussi mis sur la
prévention des risque de morsure durant
cette journée dans le département des
ivines d'autres manifestations seront
organisées jusqu'au 8 octobre pour
promouvoir l'animal préféré des
Français et quel meilleur moment que la
Journée mondiale des animaux et de la
Semaine nationale du chien pour le
retour d'une chronique d'un rendez-vous
consacrés aux animaux dans le 78 avec un
changement de nom la chronique au poil
devient les animaux du ite tout
simplement ATIS Baré conseillè municipal
en charge du bien-être animal à poissie
vous donne quelques conseils pour
prendre soin de vos fidèles compagnons
et ce soir vous apprend à toiletter
votre chien
[Musique]
vous-même bonjour je suis ATIS Baré
conseiller municipal à la ville de
poissie aujourd'hui nous sommes au parc
messonniers je suis avec Fannie ainsi
que Mariella pour nous expliquer un
petit peu son rituel de rentrée par
rapport à Fanny Mariella est-ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire un petit peu par
rapport à la rentrée de Fanny ce qui est
un petit rituel bien sûr alors elle
commence d'abord par prendre un petit
bain nous le faisons nous-mêmes sur la
terrasse nous la peignons elle a des
produits pour nettoyer les oreilles
c'est le vétérinaire qui s'occupe de
couper ses ongles parce que j'ai un
petit peu peur et et cette année on a
opté pour pour faire des petits plats
maison composés de Blond de poulet de
riz et d'haricot vert ce sont des choses
que les chiens peuvent manger une
rentrer au petit soin voilà c'est
[Musique]
çaah voici sa trousse en fait bah elle
est rose comme les coquettes bien
évidemment bah son
shampoing ça c'est le produit pour
nettoyer les
oreilles on nous a avant une
brosse là il y a les poils qui
sortent donc d'abord son shampoing
ensuite on la brosse voilà c'est ça et
puis ensuite on sèche bien et puis les
oreilles et bon bah là il fait chaud
mais quand il fait froid elle a le droit
de la vaseline sur les
[Musique]
coussinés voilà vous aussi prenez soin
de vos animaux surtout en cette période
où les animaux sont énormément donné
avant d'aller récupérer un animal pensez
à partir à la SPA vous avez beaucoup
d'animaux qui attendent de l'amour comme
Mariella on donne pour
[Musique]
Fanny et on parle à présent de cinéma si
je vous dis i white shut est-ce que ça
ça vous parle non pas du tout i W shut
c'est le ça vous parle Sabrina tourmets
oui c'est un film et c'est un film
absolument vous avez raison et c'est le
dernier long métrage en carrière signé
de Stanley Kubrick le réalisateur
américain est d'ailleurs mort peu après
la fin du montage de ce film sorti en
1999 au casting Nicole Kinman Tom Cruise
et c'est le coup de cœur ciné du jour de
notre réalisateur evelinois Quentin
dupi aujourd'hui je vous présenter i
watch shot un film de STAV Kubrick son
dernier film d'ailleurs et de film de
1980 avec Nicole Kidman et Tom Cruise
évidemment kubri on ne présente pas un
des réalisateurs les plus des plus
grands réateurs de tous les temps et du
coup j'ai envie de vous parler non pas
des films peut-être les plus connus que
soit 2001 ou je shining ou autre mais
son dernier film qui est pas forcément
son film le plus accessible mais qui est
pour moi un film absolument incroyable
sur la relation de couple finalement
c'est une mise en abîme de de de du
microcosme hollywoodien de la célébrité
de de de comment on scrute les stars et
ce couple parce que à savoir que Tom
Cruise et Kidman étaient en couple dans
la vraie vie quand ils ont été castés
dans comme couple dans ce film kubric à
l'époque leur avait interdit le en tout
cas leur avait demandé si vous faites ce
film vous ne prenez aucun autre film
tant qu'on a pas fini celui-ci kubric
était effectivement comme on le connaît
très exigeant très periste faisait
parfois plus de 50 60 prises pour pour
certains plans c'est aussi un film que
KCK n'a jamais vu fini il est mort 3
mois avant la sortie du film et donc il
y a encore beaucoup de débat sur à quel
point le film qu'on peut voir
aujourd'hui était son final code ou
est-ce que c'était un petit peu modifié
encore avant avant la sortie donc un
film entouré encore de plein de mystères
et et c'est aussi un film qui qui un
petit peu qui pour moi par un peu de
rêve éveillé le film est censé se passer
à New York tout a étéouré en Angleterre
Kubrick avait une peur phobique de
l'avion à refusé de de voyager en avion
et donc ils ont recréé New York en
Angleterre complètement des rues
entières et cetera donc rien que pour ça
voilà c'est un film qui interroge sur la
nature du cinéma sur ce qui est
Hollywood sur sur entre les images que
l'on voit et ce que ça nous présente où
se trouve la réalité et encore une fois
c'est fait avec toute la finesse de
kubric et cetera on a beaucoup parlé du
côté thriller érotique du fil film qui
est évidemment un aspect du film mais
pour moi c'est vraiment plus une
exploration de ce que c'est que le
couple que c'est que des relations avec
des gens qu'on connaitt depuis de
longues années et et de cette qu'est-ce
que c'est que l'intimité dans finalement
dans un couple dans une r amicale ou ou
ou amoureuse et et vraiment dans ce film
cubrick a voulu décortiquer montrer tout
tout cela presque au scalpel et et avec
encore une fois un Tom Cruise et et
Kidman absolument incroyable où Kubrick
joue sur l'ambigué entre le vrai couple
qu'il formait et le couple fictif qui
forme dans ce film donc voilà c'est un
film sur l'ambiguïé sur le rêve ou rien
de ce qu'on voit N ou en tout cas où à
chaque où toutes les images qu'on nous
présentent doivent être questionné sur
notre rapport à la réalité et et pour
moi un Cubric qui est qui est plus en
tout cas j'allais dire j'avance en âge
plus un cubri qui qui me plaît et qui
est impressionnant dans sa filmographie
et peut-être un de ses films les plus
aboutis thématiquement en tout cas voilà
i watch shot de can cubrique peut-être
pas le premier choix quand on découvre
sa filmographie mais mais un choix en
tout cas très intéressant et qui audelà
de cette thématique reste de toute façon
voilà kubric n'a fait que des chaleuvres
donc un chale de stad les
[Musique]
que allez c'est l'heure de la
météo un ciel voilé par endroit demain
matin dans les evveline le soleil sera
davantage visible dans les secteurs de
Versailles et mont-elajolie il fera en
moyenne entre 8 et 10°gr l'après-midi le
ciel voilé gagne du terrain et
concernera aussi Versailles côté
température compté 18°r dans la moitié
nord des ivelines 17° à Rambouillet et
demain jeudi 5 octobre nous fêterons les
fleurs tout de suite les invités du
[Musique]
78 les invités du 78 consacrés ce soir à
Octobre Rose le mois de sensibilisation
dans la lutte contre le cancer du sein
et je vous le disais comme chaque année
la mobilisation va être forte dans les
ivelines avec de nombreux événements et
on en parle avec mes deux invité alors
je les représente Isabelle n membre de
l'association cassiopa qui organise dans
la nuit du 7 au 8 octobre le marathon
rose qui va passer dans les ivlin et à
vos côtés Sabrina tourmetz qui est maire
adjointe en charge de l'urbanisme à
baahli la ville va organiser différentes
animations au cours de ce mois d'octobre
et notamment ce dimanche les tours de la
victoire objectif 2024 tours donc je le
disais qu'il a ce dimanche dans la ville
on va peut-être parler déjà du principe
des des deux événements Isabelle no
alors pour le marathon rose c'est un
marathon on parle donc d'une distance de
42 km qui va se faire dans la nuit de
samedi à dimanche mais c'est en marchant
c'est bien ça en marchant tout à fait
parce que pour le préciser enfin comme
je le disais tout à l'heure ciopa offre
des activités physiques surtout autour
de la rondau et de la marche et de de la
randoau pardon et du vélo comme activité
avec d'autres d'autres activités comme
de la la zumba Pilat ou autre et puis
avec du coup des programmes pour
remettre en forme ou accompagner les
femmes en traitement par exemple ou
aprèstaitement et du coup ça permet à
certaines comme moi et je suis très très
fière de participer si vous m'avez dit
il y a quelques temps que j'y
participerai je vous aurais pas cru de
participer à ce marathon qui va se
dérouler en fait ça donne un petit coup
de de plus aussi sur le parcours du
marathon du JO 2024 et qui représente
également qui reprend la marche des
femmes du 5 octobre 1789 un des
événements phare de la Révolution
française exactement jusqu' versaou on
l'oublie des fois malheureusement dans
l'histoire mais il y a une marche sur
versaill marche des femmes sur versaill
tout à fait et du coup ça donne deux
deuxin deux petits coups de peps
supplémentaires et ce qui est super
important pour l'association et dont je
suis très fière de du coup de pouvoir y
participer c'est que c'est fait
effectivement sous forme de marche
l'objectif c'est pas de faire une
pouesse sport sportive c'est qu'on y
arrive toutes on pe faire en individuel
mais aussi en relais en relais tout à
fait donc soit on le fait seul pour
faire les les 42 km et soit on relais
par deux personnes c'est-à-dire qu'en
gros chacune fait 20 km et 20 km ou avec
quatre personnes où chacune fait 10 km
sur le parcours et l'objectif c'est de
marcher tout ensemble qu'on y arrive
toutes donc même si c'est à 3 km/h ça
sera à 3 kmh mais laisser personne sur
le chemin et l'objectif c'est que tout
le monde arrive au but Gabriel alors
vous l'avez dit il y a des femmes en
traitement et et des femmes qui sont
aujourd'hui guéri c'est aussi l'occasion
de créer une rencontre entre entre ces
deux groupes et qu'ell puissent échanger
ensemble c'est l'occasion mais on a de
nombreuses occasions auprès de avec
l'association puisque effectivement
c'est ce groupe là qui est constitué
c'est l'occasion aussi de se rencontrer
de donner un bol d'air un enthousiasme
qui nous aide de se soutenir et de de
continuer il y a également aussi des
proches les aidant qui peuvent
participer ce qui est aussi très
important oui ouvert à tout le monde
avec une majorité de femmes quand même
qui sont concernés on sera l'occasion de
mettre en lumière vous l'avez dit cette
pratique du sport adapté alors Sabrina
tourmetz vous AB bailli donc dimanche il
y a un événements F mais il y a d'autres
événements bien sûr tout au long de ce
mois d'octobre on parlait des tours de
la victoire circuit d'un km l'objectif
c'est de faire 2024 tours c'est aussi un
événement qui sent bon les Jio quand
même là on parle du marathon rose qui
duplique le parcours du marathon des j
là aussi il est question de faire un
petit clin d'œil aussi à ces Jeux
Olympiques oui tout à fait donc le la
municipalité et accompagné par le le
service des sports de de la de la mairie
organise le le tour les tours de la
victoire c'est un un circuit de 1 km au
départ de de la mairie qui est ouvert à
tous coureurs marcheurs enfants les plus
anciens des familles et l'objectif c'est
de récolter 1 € par par tour parcouru
c'est c'est les sommes seront reversées
à l'Institut curry et évidemment on on
profite de l'événement de l'année
prochaine pour faire l'objectif 2024
tours en référence au aux Jeux
olympiques de l'année prochaine donc un
tour 1 € et un tour on a dit d'un km
finalement c'est un un circuit assez
court c'est l'idée j'imagine c'est de
concerner le plus grand nombre que ce
soit un événement familial exactement
l'objectif c'est vraiment de réunir
toute la MAJ
la plus grande partie de notre
population et bien évidemment les
familles que personne nit peur ne
craigne de de s'inscrire ou de venir
participer à cet événement et dans cette
journée dimanche il aussi d'autres
animations autour de ces tour de la
victoire oui alors il y a d'autres
animations j'ai j'ai vu que vous aviez
passé le le programme donc voilà notre
notre flyer pouvoir le revoir s'afficher
en gros le le flyer octobre rose il y
aura des une initiation au
yoga de la zumba également et tout ça ça
démonstration de cirque par une
association pirouette donc là c'est plus
orienté pour les pour les enfants donc
d'où la la l'ouverture à à vraiment
toute la population c'est vraiment un
événement familial et et on intègre à
chaque fois nos nos associations et si
je peux me permettre on a aussi d'autres
d'autres associations qui s'investissent
dans dans cette dans cette dans cette
action et notamment un apé rose organisé
et qui qui aura lieu dans un café
associatif qui s'appelle le baayaka et
qui est ouvert aux adhérents et tous les
tous les bénéfices de la de la soirée
seront également reversés au à
l'Institut curry et on retrouve bien sûr
le le programme sur le site de la la
mairie de Ba sur le le parcours des
différents événements alors on parlait
du du marathon rose il y a il y a un
instant on disait que céit un parcours
calqué sur celui du marathon de pour
tous ce qui aura lieu pour les Jos c'est
aussi un hommage à la marche des femmes
sur versaill du du 5 octobre 1789 sans
le détailler il part de de Paris mais il
va passer par les Yvelines quelles sont
les étapes yvelinoises du coup de ce
parcours j'ai peur de de me tromper
c'est versaill et
vet ici les moulinau Versailles et
voflet je crois pour organiser tout ça
c'est j'imagine il a fallu s'y prendre
longtemps à l'avance pour ça fait
quelques mois oui alors moi je suis
adhérante c'est pas moi personnellement
qui a participé mais ça fait quelques
mois effectivement que l'association et
les membres et participe pour la
préparation parisque il y a tout à de la
sécurité aussi qui est mise en place
s'assurer que personne ne reste sur
place les coins de ravitaillement
s'assurer on reçoit des mails
régulièrement pour nous dire voilà il
pourrait y avoir des checks de sac la
lampe n'oubliez pas la lampe
frontale la couverture de sécurité un
approvisionnement même si au long du
parcours on aura aussi des points
d'approvision et vous attendez à peu
près combien de personnes pour pour cet
événement alors le l'événement est
complet parceque le nombre était limité
on est 100 100 participants parce que la
sécurité devait être organisée en
fonction du nombre donc il y a eu un
gros succès etcoup de spectateurs en
plus également en plus pour nous
applaudir et nous soutenir et très
rapidement donc àilli la boucle on l'a
dit fait 1 km elle part de la mairie
c'est ça elle part de la mairie et elle
passe un joli parc de la commune qui
s'appelle le parc de la chatanurée donc
ça fait une boucle de d'un km et donc il
reste encore des place puisqu les
inscriptions se feront sur place le le
jour J c'est bien ça tout à fait tout à
fait dit on communique au maximum
et et je pense que beaucoup de bayakois
participeront parce qu'ils sont très les
bayakois apprécient ce genre de
manifestation et notamment les
manifestations qui qui sont ouvertes à
tous très rapidement pour terminer un
mot important quand même sur la pratique
adaptée du du sport en quoi est-elle
bénéfique justement dans la la guérison
de ces ces femmes alors déjà de
s'occuper de soi c'est déjà un point
important et puis il est prouvé
aujourd'hui par la l'activité sportive
qu'on sécrète des hormones et cetera qui
permettent de lutter contre contre la
maladie qui aide à supporter les les
effets secondaires éventuellement
euh la satisfaction d'avoir réussi euh
de permettre de ressortir ensemble avec
d'autres personnes de participer de de
vous rencontrer d'autres personnes
concernées également et de partager de
voir celles qui sont réussis qui s'en
sont sortis et donné beaucoup d'espoir
donc il y a plein plein de Bénéfic ple
de Bénéfic et c'est important de les
mettre en lumière à l'occasion de cet
événement on le rappelle qui se déroule
dans la nuit du 7 au au 8 octobre ce
marathon rose avec un un passage dans
les ivelines et vous pouvez bien sûr
retrouver plus d'informations sur
casassio PA sur le site internet qui va
sans doute s'afficher en bas de l'écran
je le rappelle pour les tours de la
victoire le rendez-vous est fixé à
dimanche rendez-vous de 9h à 14h à
baayim mais on le disait il y a aussi
d'autres événements à l'occasion
d'Octobre Rose et pareil on retrouve
toutes ces informations sur le site de
la mairie de bailli merci en tout cas à
à toutes les deux d'être venu en parler
en plateau et d'avoir mis en lumière ce
mois d'Octobre Rose ce mois de
sensibilisation on le rappelle à la
lutte contre le cancer du sein avant de
vous laisser très rapidement un mot sur
un autre événement qui se déroule à
l'occasion d'octobreose ces dimanche au
parc France Miniature l'association
etlan cours c'est vous organise la 3e
édition de ces randonnées de circuits
sont prévus 5 et 7 km inscription de 5 €
gratuit pour les mineurs et les fonds
seront reversés à la Ligue contre le
cancer voilà c'est la fin de ce cette
suite merci de votre fidélité belle
soirée à tous sur
[Musique]
tv78